e aí
é bom sou a emília ou mila e sou uma
mulher guiada pelo desejo e também pela
crença de que é fundamental ouvir a voz
do coração e eu acredito que é por essa
razão é que eu estou aqui hoje para
compartilhar com vocês uma história
intensa não só uma ideia mas uma
verdadeira experiência intensa e potente
mas antes eu gostaria que vocês
observassem essa imagem
ei ei convidá-los né para junto comigo
aí vocês se colocarem no lugar daquela
peça que tá ali do lado de uma mulher
que tá com o livro imagine que eu sou
esse livro aberto para vocês e vocês são
essas esse outro que tá aí atento e para
mim ouvir para contar essa experiência
essa essa ideia e essa experiência advém
de de uma vivência né eu eu sou uma
mulher que sempre pensei em ser
professora é essa essa essa essa opção
você professora surge da de uma
necessidade mas também com o tempo essa
necessidade foi se transformando em uma
virtude necessidade porque eu precisava
de meios para poder me sustentar e poder
pagar minhas contas
a pagar minha própria escola né e com
isso eu tive que minha mãe e meu pai
diziam né que eu queria que eu fizesse
edificações quero um curso bom para as
mulheres porque ela na escola técnica
que era o ensino gratuito e de qualidade
e também porque era uma promessa né de
futuro promissor por que ela tinha
muitos homens e provavelmente eu poderia
ter um bom casamento mas infelizmente eu
não passei no exame desse curso da
escola técnica nem tão-pouco casei com
um homem mas casei com uma linda mulher
que também é professora como eu e além
disso eu durante o magistério eu
descobri que se podia conseguir uma
bolsa de estudos
e é para que eu pudesse não pagar a
escola minhas pais não pudessem pagar a
escola e aí eu fui me candidatei essa
bolsa de estudos era eu poderia ganhar
se eu fosse estudante ajudante de uma
professora e então eu me candidatei a
essa vaga passei consegui a bolsa e aos
poucos eu fui conseguindo a minha
independência financeira então isso dá
para mostrar que eu teria que ser
professora né é resumindo era uma opção
mais ou menos necessidade e desejo e e
por isso que eu me tornei professora eu
iniciei a minha experiência como
professora não a turma de alfabetização
e eu vivi muitos desafios e alegrias e
também emoções em vivenciar essa
potência que é aprender ensinar as
crianças a ler e escrever e eu pude me
conectar com essa ideia com essa
experiência no alto do moura na praça do
artesão alcon
e as crianças de brincadeiras infantis
que é lá na praça é um espaço onde as
pessoas vivenciam as brincadeiras
infantis e aí é essa imagem aí ela
mostra um pouco isso né ela mostra esse
encontro de um grupo de por moradores
com artesãos com professores com até
compadre da comunidade onde a gente
compartilhou e um grupo também de
mediadores de leitura que realiza um
trabalho potente de muita potência em
recife nas comunidades de periferia de
olinda recife e jaboatão e na
convivência com esse grupo de mediadores
de leitura a gente pintam os como
compartilhando essa ideia junto com a
comunidade com as crianças é com os
moradores os artesãos e artesãos a gente
então é pensou em criar essa essa
biblioteca então a ideia é
e é essa essa essa ideia de criar
biblioteca também advém de uma crença é
de que é importante dar oportunidades
para que as pessoas né e esse esse livro
que tá que aparece aí é fruto de uma
pesquisa realizada por três
pesquisadoras é que recente lançado
recentemente que é o brasil que lê
bibliotecas comunitárias e resistência
cultural é esse essa é pesquisa é fruto
de uma ampla pesquisa realizada sobre
eventos de leitura e práticas em
comunidades de periferia e mostra que
diferente da crença que a gente tem de
que a população brasileira não lê essa
pesquisa mostra que de fato é possível é
coloca otivar desde cedo esse hábito da
leitura nas crianças e jovens então aí é
a gente tem uma imagem que
oi gente esse encontro é além dessa
desses grupos de mediadores a gente
também com se conector não é com jovens
estudantes universitários que realizam
um trabalho lá nós sábado sábado à tarde
e a potência dessa dessa espaço de
leitura na formação de leitores na
comunidade se revela pela pela
persistência pela resistência dessas
crianças e jovens que vão até a minha
casa para tentar cobrar de que esse
espaço deveria estar aberto para eles
poderem ferir acesso e frequentar lá e
aí mostra as crianças participando de
atividades junto com esse grupo de
estagiários do do centro acadêmico do
agreste da universidade federal de
pernambuco então a biblioteca ela nasceu
de uma
é desse grupo né a gente recebeu
atualmente a gente é realiza as
atividades no espaço alugado né mas eu
costumo dizer que ela é um lugar de sair
da prisão para libertar pessoas por quê
porque a comunidade entendeu e do um
espaço que antes tinha sido uma um posto
de enfermagem um posto telefônico e até
um espaço de aprisionar pessoas e hoje
ela se transforma nesse espaço de
liberdade liberdade libertar pessoas e
aí nessa imagem é aparece exatamente
isso não é o grupo de pessoas que a
gente conseguiu mobilizar artesãos
moradores crianças jovens professores a
própria escola onde a gente realiza essa
atividade para que eles possam se
engajar inclusive com doação de peças
nessa experiência entre
e a gente conversou também com um grupo
de jovens arquitetos daqui da cidade de
caruaru e eles chegaram a desenvolver um
projeto arquitetônico que futuramente
será o espaço da biblioteca e aí a festa
literária do alto do moura eu costumo
dizer que a biblioteca já nasceu a
mostrada enxerida porque ela trouxe
aflao que é a festa literária do alto do
moura essa festa ela é uma vivência
muito democrática e singular onde a da
abertura para várias pessoas eles
realizarem o trabalho lá de troca de
experiências e conhecimentos então a
festa literária do alto do morro eu
costumo dizer que ela uniu né a
literatura ao bairro e por quê porque a
gente tem é nessa peça daí não é uma
peça que é a logo da biblioteca ela
nasceu de um sonho da artesã terezinha
de
e ela me disse aflita que sonhou
desesperadamente que uma criança sem
cabeça uma menina sem cabeça mas ela
procurava um sonho onde estava a cabeça
da menina e no lugar da cabeça ela via
um livro e nas mãos da menina ela via
uma cabeça então esse sonho da terezinha
gonzaga expressa é um pouco dessa desse
movimento e desse envolvimento é que a
comunidade e acolheu essa ideia no
sentido de que mesmo sendo pessoas que
foram tiveram uma precariedade nesse
universo da cultura letrada eles não
deixam de acreditar no fortalecimento
das suas histórias de suas vidas a
partir dessa vivência e pensando também
nas futuras gerações então essa peça
hoje ela se chama liberdade é uma é uma
artesã que é uma liderança também é
é uma liderança abraçou a ideia da
biblioteca e hoje essa logo da
biblioteca além dessa peça a gente
também teve como
a ideia é essa uma outra peça também
criada pela nice minha filha é a peça
chamada pé de livro onde ela também é
uma um movimento interessante que surge
dela ter construído essa peça e junto
com a peça na feitura da peça ela deixa
brotar poesias e aí ela me entrego a
peça junto com a poesia isso tudo no
movimento da da dessa mobilização da
comunidade em relação a esse espaço
potente de leitura e aí é o que a gente
vê que pelo menos na minha cabeça a
primeira imagem que vem de peças de
barro da arte do barro geralmente eram
mulheres carregando bacias baldes coisas
de objetos dos afazeres domésticos e a
gente vem vivenciando junto com os
artesãos e artesãs de que a biblioteca
tem sido plantada na comunidade e fez
surgir também aqui
é de peças onde o universo do livro e da
leitura começam a compor a criação é do
barro dessas desses artesãos e artesãs
então esse pé de livro e a peça
liberdade que eu mostrei assim como
essas outras que estão aqui na imagem
também essa do severino vitalino antes
de falecer ele criou essa peça e do ou
também porque é faz parte também da flau
a doação de peças pelos artesãos que
reflitam a temática do universo do livro
da biblioteca da contação de história
então o seu severino vitalino fez essa
peça linda também como se fosse um avô
contando histórias dando conselhos para
os netos a partir da leitura e essa daí
também uma artesã aliene fez uma peça
representando o espaço da biblioteca ou
seja como é que eles imaginam a
biblioteca dentro da comunidade e também
aquela ali de bonecas leitoras né então
é essa a gente começou haver uma mudança
na própria foto criação das peças dos
artesãos durante esse movimento da festa
literária de peças é incorporando esse
universo da leitura da cultura escrita
então a festa literária é do alto do
moura para gente é uma experiência vem
sendo uma experiência desafiante onde a
gente acredita é na potência desse
espaço tanto da biblioteca como da festa
literária em seis passos que promovam
uma ampliação do processo de
democratização da leitura e da escrita
sabendo que a gente vive num país onde
as marcas da desigualdade e da exclusão
social são gritantes né o genocídio a
questão da do preconceito então todo
esse esse movimento é também na
tentativa de tocar no coração das
pessoas e fazê-las
o qual se colocar nesse lugar de a
colher é discuta de empatia não é com
outro de solidariedade esse é o que a
gente vivendo nessa experiência da
biblioteca no alto do moura e também
esse é um é um grupo potente né eu
gostaria de agradecer a todas as pessoas
que comigo vem lutando para que manter
esse espaço vivo na comunidade é esse
grupo aí foi o grupo da última festa
literária do alto do moura e mostra como
é de fato uma movimento que vem se
fortalecendo ao longo dessa trajetória
né e aí são cenas onde a gente vê a
ocupação das crianças por esse espaço né
é de fato produzindo sentidos e
provavelmente dando esperança e sonhos
para o futuro dessas crianças muito
obrigada
e aí